et si dans quelques années notre monde
hyperconnecté était totalement dépendant
des écrans pour sa nouvelle création
écran noir la compagnie déclic théâtre
met en scène une dystopie qui se déroule
en 2035 la surconsommation technologique
et la raréfaction des ressources
énergétiques qu'on traîne la société a
changé ses habitudes
cette pièce nous permet de suivre le
parcours de 6 âmes égarées accro aux
écrans il ya une de ces personnes qui va
être recruté par cette communauté
étrange en tout cas qui s'appelle screen
l'ess qui propose de désintoxiquer les
gens des écrans et cette personne va
animer ce village avec cinq autres
participants qui vont être les
stagiaires addiction aux réseaux sociaux
harcèlement numérique
plusieurs thèmes autour de l'impact des
écrans dans nos vies sont abordés au
cours de la pièce un travail de création
qui s'est fait avec des artistes
associés la compagnie trappistes a
notamment fait appel au metteur en scène
laurent mazet et ils viendraient nommer
neal a eu il est venu souvent travaillé
avec déclic théâtre et on a des valeurs
communes sur
le théâtre citoyen sur sur le théâtre
comme vecteur d'émancipation et de
réflexion de notre monde
en résidence à la maîtrise la compagnie
peaufine les derniers détails lors des
répétitions certains textes sont réécrit
avec les comédiens ce qu'ils veulent
l'idée du spectacle un peu chorale avec
six personnages et six profils
différents on aborde en fait si point de
vue qu'on pourrait avoir sur le rapport
aux écrans et l'idée plutôt de délivrer
un message c'est justement de poser des
questions et qu'à la fin en fait ce
spectacle là soit matière à débat une
satire drôle noir acide et d'actualité
qui fait réfléchir sur l'omniprésence
des écrans dans notre société